The joe rogan experience.
When I lived in New York,
I had a friend,
uh,
who,
one of his friends knew the guy's
a fucking cock odd connection,
but it was a,
there was,
there were all in music business
like rock and roll guys.
Like one of them was in this band and he
knew a dude who somehow or another new,
someone who bought Jackie Gleason's
old home and Jackie Gleason.
This is the story.
Jackie Gleason is obviously third hand,
it could be total horsemen.
That's it.
The story was,
and it's a fun story.
The Jackie Gleason was drinking with
Nixon and him and Nixon were buddies and
that,
you know,
they're talking football and throwing
back some fucking Jack and cokes and a
Nixon's like you want
to see a fucking Ufo.
So they get,
they get an air force one and they fly
some military base where they've got a
crashed flying saucer and Jackie
Gleason from then on becomes a crazy,
a UFO believer.
And Jackie Gleason has this backyard in
upstate New York and he has a fake Ufo
designed and built in his driveway
to replicate the thing that he saw.
He hires a bunch of people
to try to recreate something.
He puts it together in his head,
sort of like a crime sketch.
Like you would try to reenact it.
Funny Story.
That's the fun.
Do you believe it?
I would like to find my,
my,
I did fuck up my computer.
It's not working.
Luckily I've got backups.
[inaudible] yeah,
you're drunk.
Why don't you get your slurry mix slurs.
How'd you get that chemical that you
could just put it on your computer?
Are we good idea?
Um,
all right buddy.
But I don't know if
Jackie Gleason really did.
Why don't you Google it?
Find out did Jackie Gleason a really
wasn't really any UFO was Jackie Gleason
and the Ufos,
it'll I,
well,
Joe Rogan once said,
I spread my own fucking
like the PTO inflation.
I like the story.
I'll make up a story.
Dot.
Not even realize it.
Made it up.
Put it out there and then I'll find
it on Wikipedia and I'll use it as a
reference to prove when
I tell the story again,
trip to the alien morgue.
Wow.
So this is a real rumor to the moon,
Alice.
There was a time when you could say that.
Scroll that down.
Stop,
go back,
collaborate and listen.
Stop right there.
You're fucking drunk as shit,
dude.
Uh,
there was another size Jenkins,
extremely serious,
I'm sure UFO researcher and prided
himself on the huge collection of Ufr
[inaudible] books,
which numbered into the thousands
the see I call bullshit.
You know why?
I doubt there's thousands of
books written you a false,
put it back up.
What more could you say?
Like,
Oh,
uh,
you know,
and then he saw light too.
As soon as the new title came out,
even a Europe or the UK,
Jackie had a copy.
Hmm.
Well,
I don't know if it's true.
Um,
but that was the store that
this guy told me about house.
It's a dope story.
If that's true,
if the Jackie Gleason really was some
sort of a crazy UFO fanatic and that
that's the motivator,
more match and if it's fucking true,
oh,
it's all true.
What a beautiful thing it would be if
they really did have like a hanger 18 you
know what I want when we're old and
we're sitting on the cove drinking our
drink,
looking at the water just mean you gray
or silver bags and someone's going to
go,
you know what,
fucking Jackie Gleason went
to area 51 and saw that shit.
I wonder what's going to happen.
Yeah,
I wonder.
I wonder if it will happen.
I wonder if they really do have something.
I mean,
that would be,
I would wish one person who was lid,
legitimately intelligent who was dying,
which spill the beans.
I wish every dude that
spills the beans like,
man,
you're a fucking Weirdo.
I'm not my by one chive and with my one
thing is how impossible would it be to
keep a secret and today it
would be too impossible.
You know?
One person would say something.
I don't agree with that because they look,
they kept a secret when they were
making the Manhattan project,
but that was a different era.
What one thing I will say,
one thing is maybe those movies and
TV shows and leaks and everyone,
because we're all like,
oh yeah,
area 51 of course it's the aliens.
Like maybe that's,
you know,
maybe that's part of it.
Well look,
we know that secrets can be kept.
Secrets totally can be kept because we
didn't find out about the Gulf of Tonkin
until like way,
way late.
Like there was some people involved
in the Gulf of Tonkin incident.
When did it become mainstream?
Now look,
30 years,
40 years secrets can be kept.
Yeah.
But nowadays it's,
it's,
it's pretty deep.
Secrets can be kept out.
Wouldn't the most important
secret be we found aliens.
That would be like one of the greatest
secrets you would ever want to keep.
Like the last thing we want is these
motherfuckers just freaking out because
there's aliens.
I liked the movies though,
where it's just a given.
They're like,
yeah,
well we just got the
spaceships from area 51 yeah.
How many movies in that though?
A lot.
Most movies when they try to depict what
it would be like if we were attacked,
it's fucking terrible.
I like the fact that we started
off with saving democracy and,
well,
you got drunk along the way and
so it shifted to alien power.
Standard area.
Bitch,
when are you going looking for him?
Come on.
You and dean Cain fucking get up.
He's got that show on spike.
I'll do it as a girl.
Ever scored it on you before.
Are you reading my brain?
Are you part of the MSA?
Is this,
is this lion's drunk?
The NSA has given you all my
information having recently.
All right.
I love you guys.
Wow.
Brian,
I love you.
Okay.